the ramsgate futuretown investment plan
sets out a strategy for the town driven
by local people it offers your vision
for the future of ramsgate
this vision is a collaboration that will
be delivered in partnership with local
businesses organizations the community
and a range of public bodies like
historic england and kent county council
the plan was shaped by talking to the
community to find out what is important
to you it hopes to revitalize ramsgate's
economy
address deprivation creating new and
better opportunities for local people
give ramsgate a greater sense of
identity
enable ramsgate to become a place where
people want to live and visit
create a better connected town that
people can walk about
ramsgate is set to benefit from a range
of funding programs including the
levelling up fund high street heritage
action zone and the future high street
funds and this town investment plan will
ensure the money is invested effectively
so local people can see positive changes
in their town
the plan includes projects which funding
has already been secured as well as
outlining significant aspirations for
the future the aim of incorporating
these aspirational projects is to help
leave it in additional grant funding and
investment to support these activities
the plan focuses on four geographical
areas
the first area is the town center local
people think the centre of ramsgate is
neglected unattractive and unwelcoming
the town investment plan sets out an
approach for creating spaces for
businesses to develop and the community
to come together
refurbishing repairing and reactivating
buildings which are not in use
making the town centre a more
environmentally friendly place by
promoting walking and cycling
creating new public spaces is also a
priority
the town centre will be a community and
business hub it will be more active more
attractive and more green
a respondent to the community
questionnaire described the royal
harbour as a jewel in the crown of
planet that needs polishing
projects in this area will protect
retain and secure the future of the
harbour the intention is to improve the
areas where people walk especially along
the waterfront developing the area as a
visitor attraction enhancing the
hospitality offer and creating
opportunities for training and
upskilling local people there will also
be support to help ramsgate's fishermen
and other businesses grow and develop
the port of ramsgate is a key strategic
site and this plan sets out to create a
modern resilient port initiatives such
as the green campus a project to improve
skills and provide quality workspaces
for new green low-carbon businesses
would create a future-facing economy
that benefits ramsgate and creates jobs
for local people tree planting public
realm investment and park and walk
facilities have also been identified to
deliver an inclusive walkable coastal
location where people will want to spend
time
finally eastcliff projects in this area
include the creation of a park along
victoria parade improvements to existing
public spaces and infrastructure
investment in attractions including the
granville theatre and ramsgate tunnels
as well as a new leisure facility the
idea is that eastcliff becomes a
thriving coastal location for residents
and visitors to enjoy
supporting these four geographical areas
is the need for connections so the fifth
strand of the plan is to create a town
that is easy to get around a town that
connects people to amenities and
opportunities this includes better
connecting residential areas such as
newington to the town centre
securing investment across these five
strands has been prioritized to deliver
a ramsgate that is historic resilient
creative inclusive and fun
this video is just an overview of the
ramsgate future town investment plan and
its aspirations you can read the plan in
full find out more and join our mailing
list at ramsgate
future dot co dot uk